now milwaukee with the shot clock
turned off can hold for a potential
game-winner
crowd rising to its feet
middleton five seconds left in overtime
middleton with two middleton
he got it with point five to go
chris middleton puts the bucks up two
and he hits the bottom of the net 10 for
22 from the floor today
and just a great offensive display
by middleton coming into this particular
series
and this playoff driving inside with the
knock away by
giannis this is affecting jimmy butler
nice
chase down block here by antetokounmpo
takes it in for two true holiday
they go inside nice knock away by portis
forbes will save it back off to drew
holiday
down the middle puts on the brakes and
fires
what a display by the bucks this is
getting ridiculous
connington's got it chris middleton back
in the game
and he'll throw hold on for giannis with
a great feed on top from middleton
here by auntie dicombo and how about
this
double high rub giannis rolls
and they're gonna have to figure out a
way to stop middleton
how do they get to down low and it's
portis
of course in miami and all the injuries
they've endured
losing jalen brown in boston miami's had
their issues
giannis fires one down at an exclamation
point
for milwaukee and it is turning into a
victory lap
for the joe harris fakes drives can't
finish
the follow from when brown won't go and
here comes that pedogoombo
drives hard and throws it down
well giannis here getting stops a
defensive rebound
drew holiday kicks it back out lopez
tucker finds it to the koopa once again
the slam and brooklyn needs timeout
a multiple pass sequence holliday lopez
tucker
and then giannis for the emphatic
finish 16 seconds remaining
and deciding not to call a timeout
holiday spin move gets inside
with 11.4 remaining
drew holliday puts the walking up it's
nets ball when we come back
open safety protocols has been a star in
europe
he's trying to make his way back into
the nba he's been a big part
oh middleton counted out
first free throw of the game from
milwaukee
shaman picks up his foul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
true holidays all beautiful feed and the
slave from giannis
the dime delivered by drew making a play
giannis with attack finish at the rim
happy holiday
[Music]
nutmeg right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's a learning play for giannis
too
oh harry was right there and had it
thrown right back
[Applause]
and their great day punctuated by the
terrific block
by adeta kupo and then the beautiful
lob as giannis runs to the rim
there's the red he saw the opener he
drives
[Applause]
dunk it home on them and great defense
connecting catching through three
halfway down and out
antenna oh flex on a miata
are strewn all across the lane there's a
mushroom cloud
underneath with all the physical play
going on doris
but giannis antenna
slams at home and vanasis
four second differential
holliday about the steps sets it up for
giannis
beautiful pass and the foul
then giannis attacks the basket
beautiful pass and delivery
and three-point play opportunity a
minute
five remaining
is
[Applause]
weak side looked like durant had him
beat but lopez
timed it perfectly doing a great job of
attacking that offensive glass
four-second differential shot block game
clock
[Applause]
putting it down and the bucks have a
three-point lead
[Applause]
attacking that paint area you think this
is going to be a dunk
and just switches it midair right around
clint capela
[Music]
that light on you got a 7 of 10 from the
field
15 points seven rebounds four
assists lopez gets inside and stunts
beautiful feed from middleton off the
pin from bobby portis
and it's brook lopez going left on
forbes for the jumper
here's giannis going right at lou
williams
and putting it down agolinari here's the
lead pass
to giannis finish at the rim
pops up 39-28
middleton
look at this beautiful lead pass here by
middleton
there's only one man in this building
that can get that and he got it
[Applause]
[Music]
at some point they're gonna put a run
together very much like they did in game
three
nice pass cappella rejected by
undertakumbo
and the foul committed by blue williams
by giannis
meet me at the summit details clint
capela
46 percent watch this 35
here is yadas
soaring high to put it down
i mean this is one dribble after coming
off that
high screen and roll with tucker and
just takes flight
or getting royalties from them huh
just came on
a slam by lopez
well a rookie out of usc
what a beautiful dunk right here
originally a first round pick of the
chicago goals and spent three and a half
seasons
with chicago here's lopez and puts it
down
it all starts with the switching of
lopez
it puts too much pressure on your
defense paul deflects it
crowded and bridges bridges up inside
blocked by agent kubo
what a recovery when the bucks come the
other way
holiday spins layup shot will go and
lopez is fouled
for a guy with a hyper-extended knee
what a fantastic defensive play
this is reminiscent of lebron james
in cleveland against golden state what
an effort
[Applause]
incredible block
he only knows one way to play just
perfect timing
[Applause]
booker against holliday inside block
from behind
holiday behind the back middleton back
to holiday
inside portis for the slam
and the bucks go up 10. finals for the
bucks
and they've got it done on a defensive
end and off of the great defense
outstanding transition offense the
willingness to turn down a good shot for
a better one
giannis appreciating the stellar job by
his teammates i tell you what
it's too complicated
now booker with tucker on him throws it
up for ayton
shot blocked by antenna what a block
from giannis
he looks up drives throws it up no good
rebound [ __ ]
sons have the timeout decide not to call
it
[ __ ] the drive gets inside leans in
knocked away and stolen by holiday
phoenix has to foul
throws it down gets into the pitcher
comes up with the strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout rebound
crowder
oh money williams says mikhail bridges
running the floor shot blocked by
antenna
once again comes out of nowhere and
throws it off the backboard
janus down the other
[Music]
[Applause]
just a tremendous in transition chase
down play
great run by bridges could have easily
[Applause]
fed a couple holiday the drive finds
lopez coming and slamming
brook lopez with authority and the bucks
go up by three
this is a great job diving without the
basketball this time
catches it off the feed from holiday
and dominating
holiday finds some room kicks it out
connoisseur
middleton inside nice century pass and
the slam from the tenokubo
on the offensive end catch finishing
traffic
over everybody